So Donald Trump was asked real questions by
a female reporter during yesterday's White
House coronavirus press briefing.
He was visibly rattled.
He pulled the.
Who were you with?
Condescending question.
Then he tells her to relax.
Then he tells her she's being too loud.
These are all classic moves by Republican
politicians against female reporters.
Let's get right into it.
This is where Jia Jiang from CBS News.
Same thing about you that you should have
warned them the virus was spreading like wildfire
through the month of February instead of holding
rallies with thousands.
Why did you wait so long?
Who are you?
Who you were?
Why did you not have social distancing until
March 16?
Who was judging with CBS News?
This is how Republican men often react to
real questions from female journalists.
Those entitled women, who do they think they
are?
Who are you with?
Do you work here?
Could you possibly be a real reporter?
Disgusting.
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
did essentially the same thing recently.
This was just a few weeks ago, remember, and
none of the debate had been held in public.
There is virtually no public debate on what
looks to be the largest bill in American history.
Can you explain why that was?
And should the public have had more time to
understand what this bill is that is meant
to help the new worker?
Yes, sir.
Where the elected representatives of the American
people.
So that's now a classic move.
That's part of the orthodoxy.
Who are you with?
Do you work here?
So then this continues.
And as Trump lies and doesn't answer Jang's
questions, she doesn't let him get away with
it.
And so then Trump pulls the relax card.
Relax, sweetie.
You're getting all worked up about what the
men are doing in the room.
Take a look at this.
So if you look at what I did in terms of cutting
off or banning China from coming in national,
by the way, not Americans who are also national
listeners.
Just relax.
Nice and easy.
This is not how Trump treats male reporters.
This entire patronizing, supercilious behavior.
And then the cherry on top is that Trump tells
her to keep her voice down.
I did not all have to do is look good.
Anybody knew.
It's just.
Are you ready?
How many cases were in the United States where
I did my bad?
How many people had died in the United States?
You didn't keep your voice down.
Please keep your voice down.
Did you know how many how many how many cases
were in the United States?
I did a ban.
Keep your voice down.
So we don't often do these stories about just
like this guy's clearly just being a misogynist.
But this is clearly one of those stories.
And how brilliant would it have been if Wagih
Yang had said, how dare you?
Do you speak to your mistresses that way?
And of course, she never would have been allowed
back in the press room.
Obviously noticed that even despite all of
this, Trump never answered her actual question,
which was why were you doing huge rallies
in February?
Despite having our first case in January and
Trump won't answer and instead attacks her
three times asking Who are you with?
Saying Nice and easy, nice and easy, relax,
and then telling her to keep her voice down.
And the voice down thing is actually interesting.
Dr. Brooks has a similar voice to Wagih Jack.
It's just their voices, right.
And I've never commented on this because it's
quite relevant, in fact.
But during my livestreams, whenever Dr. Burk's
speaks, I see people in the live chat saying,
oh, Dr. Dr. Brooks talks so loud and she's
so shrill and whatever.
And I don't find it worthy of comment.
And it does strike me as sort of misogynistic
in nature.
But that's what makes this all the more absurd
here, that the problem is Wagih Jang's voice.
When Dr. Burke speaks with the same voice,
the difference as when Trump says, keep your
voice down.
It's not actually about Jang's voice, it's
about the words and the questions that she's
asking.
And case in point, right wing extremists network
0a and their reporters often have to yell
from the back of the room because they don't
actually have a seat at these press briefings.
So they're yelling questions from the back.
They just are asking softball questions.
So Trump, instead of saying keep your voice
down to the way end reporters, says, what
a nice question.
He's actually done it a bunch of times.
It would have been just delightful to see
another reporter say, Mr. President, or sir,
as he likes to say, is it appropriate to tell
a reporter doing her job to relax and keep
her voice down?
Or is that the exact patronizing behavior
that has led to you giving mistresses six
figure payouts to keep their mouths shut?
Of course, that reporter also would have been
kicked out of the room.
Now, last thing on this, not not to psychoanalyze
this, but Trump seems like a guy who does.
Really have meaningful relationships with
women, Melania Trump included, by the way.
Nor with his mistresses, as evidenced by giving
them six figure payouts.
There seems to be an insecurity there with
women where Trump becomes threatened by women
who are assertive and confident, like with
Jeff Yang, who also have the potential of
making Donald Trump look really bad.
Which she did, by the way, effortlessly.
And the whole point of Trump's answers is
to make her seem like she's out of line, which
she's not.
And then in the end, the Trump supporters
who were tricked by Trump into voting for
him in the first place, they're posting all
over the Internet.
The reporter is out of line and she's merely
trying to embarrass embarrass the president.
It's called doing journalism.
And it really exposes Trump just being fundamentally
threatened, essentially by strong women who
are not just cowering down and accepting a
payout from Donald Trump, as so many women
have done.
And the psycho analysis of Trump right there